bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france donc je les dis
le premier ministre actuel doit
présenter sa démission il va le faire
selon vous il n'a pas le choix
je pense qu'il va essayer d résisté
parce que c'est la stratégie mise en
place par le fonds commun pour le congo
la plateforme de joseph kabila essayé de
résister autant que possible mais que ce
soit des recours devant les institutions
les autres institutions judiciaires
il n'y a pas beaucoup de chances que ça
aboutisse je pense que ça fait de
prendre un peu de temps mais il finira
par démissionner alors pour qu'on
comprenne bien ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en république démocratique
du congo on avait quand même le
sentiment au moment où felice qui est
d'y accéder au pouvoir qu'il avait
bénéficié d'un soutien de son
prédécesseur joseph kabila aujourd'hui
ils mènent une offensive contre lui
quelle est la situation
c'est un constat aussi des chèques et
parce que il y a deux ans lorsque le
deux alliés aujourd'hui ex-allié joseph
kabila et félix tshisekedi ont signé
leur accorde et qualys y en a il été
question d'émettre en place plusieurs
programmes plusieurs réformes notamment
en ce qui concerne les finances
publiques en ce qui concerne les deux
contre la corruption des réformes
sociales aussi pour essayer d'améliorer
le bien-être et congolais mais force est
de constater que deux ans plus tard ces
réformes n'ont pas eu lieu il ya eu
beaucoup des blocages c'est que ces
plans félix tshisekedi alors ils
voulaient sait ménager un peu plus de
marge de manoeuvre parce qu'il n'avait
pas à la majorité parlementaire même
s'ils étaient dans cette coalition pour
les la coalition majorité parlementaire
d'enquêté dominé par les fc céder son
acier ancien allié aujourd'hui de votre
commune a donc il a essayé aussi
progressivement donc de récupérer un peu
ce contrôle qui lui échappe et sur les
institutions congolaises
vous parlez de majorité c'est une
majorité quand même où on retrouve des
pro kabila comment
l'assemblée nationale a pu obtenir a pu
faire tomber l'actuel premier ministre
comment ça s'est passé ça s'est passé à
plusieurs temps il ya eu d'abord la
menace de dissolution parce qu'il est
président la tunique voulait à tout prix
avoir cette majorité parlementaire dont
qui la menace est destitué de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale au cas où il
n'arrivait pas à voir cette majorité est
au tour du président kabila yari aussi
un sentiment de désespoir parce que
depuis quelques mois le président un
ancien président accumule des défaites
politiques
il se souviendra que le président
feltesse et qui dit a fait une mise en
place au sein de l'armée sans l'accord
de joseph kabila il a récemment nommé
trois juges constitutionnels malgré
l'opposition de joseph kabila à un
moment donné ses lieutenants la plupart
en tout cas on commençait à se dire
peut-être que leur mentor ne pouvait
plus nous ne pouvait plus protéger leurs
intérêts alors hissé sont à retourner
contre lui pour suivre
felixc j'ai dit mais les défis restera
justement la capacité définit ce qui est
dit a imposé son agenda politique avec
cette coalition qui s'annonce très haut
ça vous dire qu'à une perte d' influence
de joseph kabila dans le pays avec
telles conséquences
la principale conséquence c'est le
changement des statuts una il a dirigé
le pays pendant dix huit ans il avait
des réseaux partout il était vraiment le
maître à bord le seul maître à bord
pendant très longtemps prendre deux de
sni et aujourd'hui il est entraîné
d'encaisser des coups et il s'est
retranché derrière dans le sud du pays
dans sa ferme et il a mis en place un
comité des crises ou autour de lui pour
essayer dans un premier temps
d'identifier un lieutenant qui lui sont
fidèles et peut être affinée une
stratégie de la poste mais on sait
dessine plus vers un tamis la chiffres
défilent mais l'opposition des mains
l'actuel premier ministre qui doit
présenter sa démission
que lui reproche-t-on précisément est ce
qu'il ya des accusations de
option au tour justement du clan pro
kabila
sur le papier il ya plusieurs griefs qui
tourne essentiellement sur la non mise
en oeuvre de son programme de
gouvernement et aussi mais en réalité si
le premier ministre a été destitué hier
c'est surtout parce qu'ils et au sein
des institutions encore en place au
congo il demeurer l'un des principaux
maillons maillons du dispositif mais
l'ancien président joseph kabila donc
qu'il fallait qu'ils sautent comme les
autres fusible qui ont sauté peu avant
lui le bureau de l'assemblée nationale a
été destitué aussi donc ça participe à
cette inversion du rapport des forces en
cours en république démocratique du
congo le président de la république qui
est arrivé au pouvoir
très minoritaire très fragile parce
qu'ils étaient encerclés entouré par les
camps kabila est entrée aujourd'hui de
reprendre le dessus sur les institutions
donc c'était dans l'ordre des choses de
les pousser à la porte le premier
ministre qui était un pro kabila
on se souvient d'équateur et en décembre
dernier à l'assemblée nationale il ya de
vraies tensions est ce que justement ce
bras de fer entre les pro kabila et
philippe tout ce qui est dit l'actuel
président peut conduire le pays dans une
crise profonde voire des violences
on est dans une crise
on est dans une crise déjà c'est une
étape de plus dans cette crise je disais
tout à l'heure que le président de la
république s'est retiré dans le sud du
pays il est dans les eaux katanga et on
entend de plus en plus de 2 des voix
dans cette partie du pays qui appellent
même à des moules à peine voilée à la
sécession à à la violence dont il ya eu
des arrestations et ça m'a encore d'un
pasteur un ancien président de la
commission électorale qui qui qui a
insinué ccir élan sécessionnistes ya les
risques
il ya des risques de violences mais la
situation au niveau des larmes et pour
l'instant est calme et on observe mai
il ya des risques et ça dégénère alors
la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
ce que ça va ça va se faire comme en
talent et le calendrier pour l'instant
le l'informateur modeste bahati qui a
été décidée désigné est en train de
peaufiner la récolte deux déclarations
individuelles chaque député doit saunal
solennellement s'est positionné dire
s'il appartient à l'opposition à la
majorité
donc la prochaine étape sera déjà de
mettre en place le bureau définitif
parce que l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
de bureau définitif
donc ils vont installer le bureau
définitif de l'assemblée nationale
identifier clairement cette nouvelle
majorité parlementaire qui s'est
constituée autour du du président de la
république et c'est au sein de cette
nouvelle majorité que sera que le
président de la république choisira à
son premier ministre dément merci
beaucoup à vous trésor à qui bon goût là
je rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique au groupe d'étude pour le
congo